bonjour et bienvenue dans ce cas les
missions qui parle de vivre ex parle des
sciences humaines en ce quatrième
épisode on va s'intéresser à un sujet
qui est particulièrement sensible au
sein du débat public français j'ai bien
sûr nommé li cela pour aborder cette
question j'ai choisi de me tourner vers
un livre qui s'appelle pour les
musulmans et qui a été écrit par edwy
plenel
du coup on va parler en premier de
l'auteur et on va s'intéresser ensuite à
toutes les problématiques qui sont
évoqués dans ce livre alors du coup il
ya un beau travail donc on y va tout de
suite
[Musique]
edwy plenel est un écrivain et
journaliste français né à nantes en 1952
il passe son enfance entre la france et
les caraïbes et l'algérie où il va
débuter sa carrière universitaire de
retour en france en 1970 il va rejoindre
la lcr ou ligue communiste
révolutionnaire et deviendra journaliste
du parti durant tout son engagement ils
s'éloignèrent ensuite du parti pour
rejoindre le journal le monde en 1988
après plusieurs plus de rôles au sein de
ce journal est également plusieurs
prises de distance il va finalement
devenir directeur du journal le monde
en 1996 il va quitter le monde en 2005
et va fonder en 2008 mediapart qui est
un journal en ligne uniquement en ligne
il est participatif et il est
principalement axé sur le journalisme
d'investigation il est depuis lors
président ce média et est une figure
forte du paysage médiatique français
donc vous l'aurez compris n'est pas à
proprement parler un universitaire il
n'y a pas de docteur professeur il
répond plus à la définition de ce qu'est
un intellectuel français à savoir un
essayiste un orateur est également un
journaliste livre abordé aujourd'hui est
d'ailleurs ce qu'on appelle un essai à
savoir un ouvrage qui implique la
subjectivité de son auteur en cela le
discours peut être donc partisans ou
militants
cela la différence d'un livre d'un
article scientifique qui va essayer de
dégager la subjectivité de l'auteur pour
objectiver
même le propos même si on sait que la
subjectivité de l'auteur est toujours un
petit peu présente dans les lignes d'un
livre ou d'un article il existe une très
forte tradition de l'essai en france
c'est un genre qui est très important et
c'est une place qui a également un peu
dangereuse pourquoi dangereuse parce que
si un wc se fait passer pour un livre
scientifique
alors il peut faire passer un discours
militant pour un discours avéré factuel
alors que ce n'est pas le cas même chose
quand l'oeuvre scientifique est reçu
comme un essai et du couple heureux de
voir un accueil très relative alors
pourquoi cet essai est aussi bas
pourquoi je les choisis
il semble qu'aujourd'hui au sein du
débat public certaines idées et
certaines déclarations ne soit plus
vraiment sujet à controverse par exemple
que l'on parle automatiquement d'un
problème musulman ou que l'on puisse
plus ou moins justifiées l'époque
coloniale ou alors que des phrases
discriminante ou carrément racistes
finalement on passe un petit peu à la
sent qu'on est vraiment eu le temps de
pouvoir s'insurger contre le fait que
des choses très graves et été dit au
sein de la sphère publique
dans ce contexte il semble intéressant
dont on voit un peu dissonante qui
cherche à remettre en place et remettre
en perspective les stéréotypes qu'on a
sur les musulmans en france
cela afin d'avoir un regard peut être
plus pertinent et de remettre en
perspective les crispations identitaires
de chacun face à ces questions alors est
ce qu'on peut parler de problème
musulman quand on commence à
essentialiser derrière une religion
imaginer la violence symbolique immense
pour des compatriotes protestants ou
juifs d'entendre qu'il y aurait un
problème du protestantisme ou du
judaïsme en france derrière cela il y à
une humanité concrètes derrière une
religion il y a des gens qui ont un
rapport d'origine un rapport de culture
un rapport de croyance dans la diversité
de leur appartenance
donc cela les désigne comme notre
problème selon l'auteur sa réflexion par
d'une phrase d'alain finkielkraut
prononcer sur les ondes de france inter
en 2014 il y a un problème de l'islam en
france
une information qui n'a alors
visiblement pas soulevé d'émotion
particulière au sein de la maison de la
radio asthme
voilà précisément une phrase qui comme
plein d'autres consciente ou non tend à
stigmatiser une partie de la population
à des fins identité ainsi il est
important de souligner le nom de l'
ouvrage à savoir pour les musulmans qui
n'est tout sauf un hasard
ce titre fait directement référence à un
ouvrage d'emile zola et créé en 1896 qui
s'appelait pour les juifs
un ouvrage qui présente son très célèbre
article j'accuse en lien avec l'affairé
dreyfus à l'époque il tente alors de
mettre en lumière
l'intolérance systématiques auxquelles
sont soumis les juifs cela il a écrit
avant que cette intolérance se
systématisent notamment sous l'impulsion
de l'allemagne nazie avec les formes que
l'on connaît aujourd'hui
alors si comparaison n'est pas raison on
constate une pente dangereuse de
l'islamophobie en france c'est quelque
chose qu'on constate notamment dans
l'étude qui a été menée par la
commission consultative des droits de
l'homme qui note une progression
constante de l'islamophobie depuis 2009
une année qui correspond directement au
débat sur l'identité nationale mené sur
la présidence sarkozy
donc en 2006 le parallèle immédiat entre
l'antisémitisme du début du siècle et
l'islamophobie aujourd'hui en france ne
doit pas être fort argument il faut
quand même qu'on puisse être en mesure
de capter les enseignements du passé
cela d'autant plus que ces deux formes
de stigmatisation tendent à s'articuler
sur des principes assez similaires c'est
logique on était clairement est assez
tristement exprimé par manuel valls qui
était alors premier ministre
un gouvernement de gauche lors de ces
défis pour 2014
alors ces défis qu'elle était si
l'immigration africaine en gros il nous
envahissent la compatibilité de l'islam
avec la démocratie en gros il veut
changer notre mode de vie et la façon
dont fonctionne et enfin les
problématiques posées par leur groupe
familial en gros ils profitent de nos
lois les thèmes raciste classique pour
par les musulmans et qui aurait pu être
aussi bien des tournures que l'on a pu
retrouver pour cet antisémitisme du
début du siècle on en a parlé
précédemment pénale
également que parler d'islam pour parler
d'une certaine partie de la population
est un moyen détourné de prendre
certaines phrases que l'on prend ne
ferait pas autrement par exemple tu peux
dire est ce que l'islam est compatible
avec la démocratie
mais ce serait illégal de dire est ce
que les arabes sont compatibles avec la
démocratie alors que justement pour les
personnes qui utilisent ce genre de
stéréotypes
l'un est difficilement dissociable de
l'autre ce qui est encore une des grosse
joie de la malgache bref des
qualificatifs ou des préjugés qui ne
feront couvrir de la porte à plus de
thello type que ce soit sur les arabes
les juifs les noirs les latinos les
asiatiques bref une intolérance qui
pourra mener qu'à plus d'intolérance où
elle a cette tendance croissante à
l'islamophobie l'auteur souligne aussi
qu'il y a de plus en plus une tendance à
placer des peuples aux caractéristiques
bien différent sous une même bannière
celle à ce qu'on appelle la fable de
l'homogénéité cela en premier lieu avec
la question de l'identité française
l'identité française c'est l'outil
nécessaire d extrême c'est le fait de
dire qu'il ya un caractère absolu et
essentialiste qui regroupe les français
qui ne sont pas issus de l'immigration
récente il faut définir ensemble une
politique de l'immigration qui respecte
à la fois notre identité nationale
et bien entendu les droits de l'homme
essentialiste car cette idée voudrait
dire que il ya un caractère essentiel
des individus à faire partie d'une
nation seulement ce concept est cette
idée tend à faire oublier que le concept
même de nation c'est une construction à
ce titre un célèbre historien
britannique du nom de oaks bande temps a
précisé que c'est l'état qui fait des
nations et pas l'inversé
il explique ainsi qu'au moment où la
croyance religieuse c'est un petit peu
amoindrie dans nos sociétés et bien
cette idée de nation a surgi afin de
créer une concept pour fédérer les
hommes sous une volonté étatique commune
tout cela pour dire que parce que je
suis blanc et qu'on grand père était
déjà en france alors je fais plus partie
de la nation française que kelly team
vient d'arriver et qui vient d'obtenir
la nationalité française n'a pas
beaucoup de sens en second lieu cette
utilisation perpétuelle du principe
d'identité temps affirmé relaté que les
individus qui sont sous la même nation
ont des caractères comme un caractère
qui sont le lit même de l'exclusion en
soit l'identité nationale est aussi et
peut-être surtout un symbole d'exclusion
pour la personne qui ne la détient pas
de côté musulman non c'est à dire ceux
qu'on accuse de ne pas coller à cette
identité française leur traitement dans
l'espace public est amené à être traités
sur la même problématique de
l'homogénéité à savoir que tous ces
individus musulmans seraient traitées
dans l'espace public avant tout comme
des musulmans avant d'être traités comme
des citoyens déduire l'individu à son
caractère religieux et donc à leur
mettre en lien avec toutes les
incohérences et toutes les anachronismes
dont les religions souffre aujourd'hui
ainsi s'est impliqué que la dimension
religieuse façonne l'intégralité de
l'individu est ainsi éjecté absolument
toutes les conséquences sociales de plus
les pratiques et les sentiments
d'appartenance barry fondamentalement
d'un individu à l'autre ce qui amène une
obligation à la nuance dans le discours
et une nuance qui est trop souvent
oubliée au sein du discours médiatique
et au sein du débat public ce qui est
derrière le discours d'alain
finkielkraut derrière l'identité
malheureuse que j'ai lu de près derrière
la vulgate médiatique qu en tant
qu'intellectuel médiatique et le diffuse
c'est qu'une injonction à l'effacement
le fait que cette comparaison est que
ces parallèles puisse être fait aussi
facilement c'est aussi le pari réussi du
terrorisme c'est à dire la création
d'une diaspora musulmane stigmatisés et
isolé au sein des sociétés occidentales
un cloisonnement qui est le terreau
fertile des discours identitaire et
décloisonnement de toutes parts c'est
aussi là que réside notre responsabilité
face aux stéréotypes
un principe que l'auteur résume à ces
événements par ces mots cette réduction
des musulmans de france à un islam lui
même réduit au terrorisme et à
l'intégrisme est un cadeau offert aux
radicalisation religieuse dans un jeu de
miroirs ou l'essentialisation xénophobe
justifie et socialisation identitaire
cette discrimination et 7
essentialisation et ne vient pas de
nulle part
et si la colonisation n'est pas le seul
facteur ou même le plus grand des rangs
en fait j'en sais rien il est une part
importante de cette problématique
l'auteur souligne en premier lieu la
logique sur laquelle s'est basée cette
expansion coloniale cela à savoir qu'il
existerait une hiérarchie des
civilisations une position qui entraîne
nécessairement une infantilisation et
une déconsidération des peuples
colonisés racisme institutionnalisé un
pillage des ressources ainsi que
plusieurs conflits qui mèneront
finalement à des meurtres de masse et à
une banalisation l'utilisation de la
torture
ce que dit adji plenel c'est que la
transition qui a eu lieu entre cette
époque coloniale et aujourd'hui n'a pas
autorisé un deuil de cette période
coloniale et une acceptation de ce
qu'était finalement cette période pour
les peuples colonisateurs et pour les
peuples colonisés
l'algérie a été soumise un système
profondément injuste et brutal ainsi pas
mal dans une vision considère encore
cette période comme un échange un
échange dynamique entre deux peuples
ou alors un partage des connaissances
occultant de fait le racisme et
l'oppression subie par les peuples
colonisés une absence de deuil qui
explique assez tristement la persistance
de l'idée d'une hiérarchie des
civilisations et donc d'un racisme
latent qui est dirigée vers les
populations orientale si on évoque ici
les différentes dérives de sens qui ont
lieu notamment dans le discours
politique mais également des secondes
médiatique il est important de noter
qu'aujourd'hui ce débat etc
des considérations elles ont même lieu
au sein du débat législatif si edwy
plenel dans son livre évoque notamment
tous les débats qui a eu autour de la
déchéance de nationalité en 2014
on peut depuis aisément évoquer toutes
les dispositions de lois ou toutes les
évocations de loi qui ont eu lieu depuis
les tragiques attentats de janvier et
novembre 2015
il peut aller voir le gars et je gardais
mon pote et de dèche et ballons et des
chu et du doigté die fut d'ailleurs
des mesures ou des propositions qui
visent en premier lieu les citoyens
d'origine étrangère et qui devait créer
une législation à deux vitesses au sein
du pays une différenciation qui selon
edwy plenel créer un ennemi inépuisable
à la société dont l'irrégularité déclaré
créerait deux fait une répartie
irrégulière un danger de l'exception qui
va nécessairement créer une
intensification des discriminations un
cercle vicieux finalement qui ne peut
mener qu'à plus d'intolérance
donc voilà j'espère ne pas avoir trop
trahi l'esprit du livre et avoir pu
évoquer un petit peu la chaîne de
causalité qui peut émaner un petit peu
de toute forme de discrimination un
cercle vicieux qui peut devenir vertueux
à partir du moment où on est un prêt à
remettre en question tous les
stéréotypes qui nous entoure j'ai
conscience qu'à l'image du livre par
contre mon discours était peut-être plus
partisan que lors des précédentes vidéos
c'est en effet un sujet qui me tient à
coeur et je suis certain qu en
questionnant représentation justement on
peut faire bouger les lignes pour
poursuivre ce sujet je vous dirige à
l'accoutumée sur un livre et une vidéo
le livre en question s'appelle le mythe
de l'islamisation par raphaël liogier il
revient sur cette question de
l'islamisation de façon très chiffrée et
documenté en gros tout un ensemble
d'outils pour remettre en question ce
qu'est le danger de l'islam ou de
l'islamisation en france ce mois
document est une conférence menée par
alain badiou à la suite des attentats du
13 novembre
il revient aussi sur les différents
mécanismes de la radicalisation et
permet de bien comprendre les
différences qu'il peut y avoir entre
slam intégrisme terrorisme et voilà
c'est tout c'est tous ces maux qui sont
souvent utilisés ensemble et pourtant
qu'on dispense bien distincts et kaman
du cou à des à des choix des
chevauchements de sens qui finalement
amène à des des mauvaises vision de ce
qu'est la réalité sociale et de ce
qu'est la réalité de l'islam en france
merci à tous de m'avoir écouté j'espère
que cette vidéo vous a plu je vous
invite à discuter calmement 2
ces sujets là dans les commentaires je
vais essayer d'augmenter le rythme de
parution des vidéos parce que j'ai
vraiment plein de sujets que j'ai envie
d'aborder donc j'espère que je pourrai
c'est beaucoup de travail à chaque fois
mais je pense que en y allant un petit
peu plus fort faut le faire
en attendant je vous souhaite une
superbe journée soirée ennemis tout ce
que vous voulez et on se dit ah la
prochaine salut salut bande d'enfoirés
[Musique]